there's another aspect of this story
we're gonna get to tonight earlier today
a Time magazine headline blared the
following accused parkland shooter
Nicolas Cruz was a member of a white
supremacist group PBS aprox many others
big news organizations ran stories
claiming that this was confirmed by the
leader of this white nationalist group
except now police are saying there are
no apparent ties between a white
nationalist militia and the shooters by
the way this this group has 10 members
and is run by a complete nut bag of
rides around on a bike with a you know
he's a wet wax total whack-job joining
us now to discuss this another rush to
judgment is Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo Raymond
this is wild but they I saw this pop of
my phone I'm like my my detector my
blank Patek detector running and the
media always gets ahead of its skis on
these things because they want to get
there first they want to get the story
not just that they want him to fit a
certain problem what they want to assign
a political motive and we've seen this
again and again now today what happened
is this white supremacist Jordan cherub
who's head of this odd militia group
like a handful of people in the woods
he claimed that this kid Nicholas Cruz
trained with him in Tallahassee turns
out he was wrong but he told the
anti-defamation league in AP this story
and it's spread like wildfire but later
even the southern Southern Poverty Law
Center and others said no this didn't
happen we can't confirm this now the
Leon County Police Department says there
why would you rely but why would you
rely on this freak from this white
nationalist group as your only source of
information why headline
ding-ding-ding-ding yes allege we've
seen this before
tell me about what happened with Gabby
Giffords what Gabby Giffords in 2011
you'll remember they were blaming Sarah
Palin's year-old web site that had
crosshairs on certain districts and they
said well look there's a crosshair on
Gabby Giffords Arizona district this
must be the reason the shooter got
involved turned out to be a FEMA County
sheriff said sheriff Jerry Jared Lochner
the guy was gonna name Clarence
dump Nick heater he said that he
targeted the Tea Party in his commerce
and he said
the Tea Party creates this atmosphere
that's Jared Lochner created this
atmosphere where where people are
triggered this is Gifford shooter that
triggered this guy like the Tea Party's
to blame it was reprehensible even said
he listened to talk radio in Bloomberg
you remember with the Times Square
bomber in 2010 he said the guy may have
set off this bomb because he was upset
with the health care plan President
Obama's Thank You mayor Blanc we've got
to be very careful of these political
motives it's a rush and we undercut real
investigative reporting and law
enforcement discoveries and also we miss
the human dimension what really might be
motivating these kids to enact horrible
violence on their peers and discovering
the next kid that is an important part
of this story you hit it in the angle I
think it's right on the rush to
politicize always seems to go in one
direction meanwhile we're gonna talk to
Steve Scalise coming up in just a moment
my congressman yeah we love Steve
Scalise a Bernie Sanders supporter shot
him but that kind of got swept on to the
real fast that we don't hear about that
anymore
no no Bernie Sanders supporters saying
how they deep-sixed that but look this
is a loving it's a fast-moving story but
it will learn more it will learn more
Raymond Arroyo thank